друзі Всіх вітаю ми з Марією іоновою
їдемо на донеччину до наших друзів
військових звичайно
не було разу це
такситні там такі необхідні безпілотники
скільки б ти не передавав підрозділи
безпілотників їх треба більше і більше
тому що на жаль росіяни дуже добре
забезпечені
мають і вміють прошивати і ті
безпілотники які ми користу
ються Українські збройні сили хоча наше
ну найкраще майстри Тому це очі нашої
армії це безпека нашої армії І от я
щаслива що на мій день народження і на
Марії день народження Наші друзі там
завіз квітів подарували нам такі донати
зробили і вдалося купити кілька
безпілотників
безкоштовно обряду Едельвейс ми
виконуємо бойові завдання на Донецькому
напрямку б'ємо москаля
велику Європу Дякую всім англійським
друзям
партнером британським за підтримку нашої
держави ці засоби які ви нам передається
в тому числі Марік надзвичайно поле
віддає нам можливість і зберегти свого
життя солдата а також зробити все для
того щоб якомога більше корків
представників Росії поклала своє життя
вона в Донецькому заході на Донбасі
зараз безпекова ситуація важка те що
знаємо ми там постійно гукає але дійсно
збройні сили України крок за кроком там
метр за Метром дуже важко дуже важкою
ціною захищають і звільняють
українського землю від ворога ми бачимо
що у вас правосторонній руль теж з
Британії
Передали мені цю машину є там також Наші
друзі мої друзі українці з Болгарії
найцікавіше і вони якраз нам помогали це
красиві палковський їх там об'єднання
українців є машин вже більше треба права
сторона машину треба багато
правосторонніх але дякувати Богу ми
маємо ще можливості її ремонтувати
завдяки волонтерам І що він зусиллям
разом з друзями Ми ремонтуємо ця машина
дуже багато всього пережила між іншим ця
машина і
попадала під обстріли нею їздили хлопці
котрі е-е тоді працювали лавами
джевелінами і тим не менше ми її знов
зремонтували поставили на ноги завдяки
тернопільським волонтерам І вона далі
виконує бойові завдання
доставляє соляру в продукти харчування
на позиції А ти знаєш що до
сі Вони все це питання було вирішено це
правильно абсолютно це спростить
бюрократичну складову для
військовослужбовців для людей котрі
працюють в Збройних Сил України але я
хотів би зазначити що машина стоїть на
обліку позабалансовому але на жаль
Звичайно є проблема ключова - це не те
що вона на обліку А те що на неї не
можуть виділити е-е кошти на утримання і
на заправку саме це ми зараз маємо
вирішити і ви без сім'ї тому я це ви
молодці безцінні А ми знаєш маємо бути
вашими слугами насправді от що має бути
Я хочу щоб всі депутати були слугами
заслуги
а подяки це приємно звичайно чути від
наших військових щодо збільшення
відпустки
обираються брати відразу там 30-40 днів
тому що усвідомлюють як це може оголити
їх підрозділи але тішаться тому що тепер
є така можливість кілька разів на рік
поїхати на тиждень на
сумують за дітьми за дружинами за мамами
і звичайно для того щоб відновитися
Десь уже замало військові дуже очікують
від Верховної Ради від уряду якоїсь
адекватності конструктивності вирішення
інших соціальних питань особливо що
стосується поранених
Курсанти вірніше бо 600 гривень ну це це
смішно І звичайно повернення до плану
Особливо ми очікуємо що наступної сесії
все ж
таки мама
все ж таки допрацює той законопроект
який би все ж таки забезпечити і
гарантував ті доплати всім категоріям
військовослужбовцям в залежності від
того який бойові завдання
А ну чесно кажучи сумно хотілось би все
ж таки приїжджати з якимись результатами
27 голосів тільки за але хотілось би щоб
якісь усвідомлення те що пріоритет нашої
держави це сектор
Верховної Ради включаючи політичну волю
слуга народу головні питання от це одно
які нам наші друзі в армії задають
стосуються забезпечення
модерної технікою забезпечення
боєкомплектом боєприпасами тому що це
рятує життя і очевидно що тут потрібно
більшої все-таки допомогою наших
міжнародних партнерів от Марією Ми
займаємося із нашими колижанками саме
спілкуванням з нашими партнерами
наполягаючи на тому що час грає точно
проти України тому що ми несемо дуже
великі втрати кожне життя нашого воїна -
це велика втрата поки союзники
роздумують скільки нам дати танків Коли
нам дадуть літаки скільки нам дати
снарядів скільки дати там гранат цього
треба більше більше
і вчасно Для того щоб вчасно закінчити
Контрнаступ Ну а якщо говорити про
мотивованість наших воїнів то вона
висока тому що всі хочуть
тому що звільнити всю нашу землю дорогі
друзі для кожного з нас найкращим
подарунком є донат для ЗСУ я хочу
подякувати всім моїм друзям які замість
квітів замість цукерок замість парфумів
цього року зробили донат дуже щедрий
донат ми разом зібрали з вами
265,000 грн і сьогодні я щаслива
передати легендарній 108 10-ї бригади
108 батальйону 10-ї бригади ось такий
малес він зараз їде в Бахмут і Повірте
будь ласка дуже багато зробить там для
того щоб вбити руку Марія в якої
дослідження теж травня але трошечки
пізніше вона з плагіат але і сказала що
їй на день народження якщо Ірині Дрон то
їй треба Дрон і
от він сьогодні теж відправляється в 10
легендарну бригаду едельвейсів мочити
окупанта Андрію осіб все
м дуже щастя нас і ми можемо працювати
Дякую Ну а за кадром стоїть Андрій в
якого є ще частина мого подарунку ще
такі Дрон Камікадзе А Андрію не можна
показувати своє обличчя зараз Маша нам
допоможе ось тут все українською
розробник бачите тому що
265,000 грн вистачило на два Дрони на
мавики на откамікадзе і ми дуже щасливі
що ну це найкращий подарунок мені на
день народження
Саша е всі друзі які зробили цей донат я
вам дуже-дуже дякую А друзі Ось такі
подарунок тепер зробили мені Ну але це
наш спільний подарунок я дякую всім
колегам з різних фракцій які замість
квітів замість там ще раз кажу парфумів
кави цукерок от цього року зробили такі
донат давайте не забувати що війна
триває І щодня замість однієї чашки кави
можна задонатити для ЗСУ Слава ЗСУ і
слава Україні дуже дякуємо вам дуже
дякую